we want to let you know about a
potential new twist in the murder case
involving a missing Colorado mother
Patrick Frazee is expected in court this
Friday he's accused of killing his
fiancee Kelsey Bharath who disappeared
on Thanksgiving Day last year Janet
shamlian is following the case in
[ __ ] Creek Colorado Janet as I
understand it there are new documents
that were filed in court Tony good
morning that's right and those documents
indicate that Frazee may point the
finger at someone else when he goes on
trial in October no mention of who that
could be but it might be his former
girlfriend who's admitted to a role only
in the aftermath of Kelsey Burris murder
Patrick Frazee could be mounting a
defense that will blame someone else for
the murder of his fiancee Kelsey Bharath
when he stands trial according to newly
released court documents
Bharath was last seen in this
surveillance video shopping with her
year-old daughter on Thanksgiving
Krystal then tells us that Patrick kills
Kelsey in a horrific manner Frazee's
former girlfriend crystal Lee Kenny has
given prosecutors a horrific account of
how she says Frazee told her he
allegedly murdered the mother of his
little girl when she walks into Kelsey's
condo the scene is horrific
Kenny says Frazee told her he killed
Bharath in her home after convincing her
to wrap a sweater around her head and
guess the scent of candles and then
beating birth to death with a baseball
bat while she couldn't see after he has
put Kelsey in a black plastic tote calls
Krystal to come out and help him clean
up investigators say Kenny admitted
watching Frazee burn Barrett's remains
outside his home I think he's a very
dangerous person we spoke to Kenny's
close friend Michele Stein in February
who told us Kenny feared for her life
she had very very good reasoning for
whatever it is she may or may not have
done Kenny said initially freeze he
asked her to kill the 29 year old mother
on three occasions including suggesting
poisoning Barrett's coffee I think he is
a true narcissist
he's a master manipulator crystal Kenny
pled guilty to tampering with evidence
in the case but has denied any
involvement in Kelsey Burris murder
meanwhile the defense is asking for a
jury pool of some 300 people due to all
the pretrial publicity that motion and
several others will be ruled on here
Friday we're expecting to see Frazee in
court at that time
Anthony Janet thank you